quel est le point commun entre la ligne
d horloger une piste cyclable l
entreprise mais nié qu'ils fabriquent
des boutons l'europe
la ligne entre besançon et la
chaux-de-fonds a bénéficié d'une
subvention européenne de 760 5000 euros
pour se moderniser la piste cyclable
entre belfort et m'associe à reçu plus
d'un million pour réduire l'usagé de la
voiture
et puis l'europe à financer chez mme
aigner à lavans-lès-saint-claude le
développement de nouveaux produits pour
la bijouterie qu autres exemples
d'entreprises qui perçoit une aide
européenne
cette minoterie à fougerolles le groupe
emploie 80 personnes et veut moderniser
son outil de production
on a un projet qui nous permet à la fois
d'améliorer les conditions de travail
des gens au moulin est aussi d'améliorer
la régularité de la farine et à ce
niveau là l'europe à nous à ne pas
prêter une oreille attentive
par rapport à notre investissement
l'europe a prêté une oreille attentive
et donner une subvention de 160 mille
euros soit 20 % du coût total du projet
direction le pays de montbéliard à
audincourt bon on vous dit
et va vous coûter merci non dit merci
ces dix dernières années à audincourt
l'europe a versé 1 million 700 mille
euros avec le bailleur néolia la ville
redessine le quartier difficile des
champs-montants des immeubles ont été
démolies d'autres réhabiliter l'europe
fixe des critères très stricts mais
s'était lui ne s'en plaint même pas
l'apport de l'europe que nous permet
d'avoir des projets très qualitatif on
parlait par exemple de la réhabilitation
thermique énergétique nous permet
d'envisager des niveaux d'efficience
plus élevé que ce qu'on aurait peut-être
fait naturellement
et puis parce que bien l'europe amène
forcément une homogénéisation des
demandes qui fait que si projet quand
ils ont le label européen sont reconnus
comme étant d'un bon niveau
naturellement partout en europe dernière
réalisation en date dans ce quartier le
centre peter pan qui accueille des
associations en charge d'enfants pour un
projet comme celui que nous avons ici un
bâtiment financé à un tiers par par
l'europe et bien obtenu nous avons pu
monter largement en qualité le projet le
projet éducatif qui est derrière aussi
peut-être même n'aurions nous pas pu
faire un bâtiment recevant toutes les
associations de cette manière-là sans
l'aide de l'europe
en bourgogne franche comté depuis 2014
l'europe à verser 1 milliard 400
millions soit un budget annuel de la
région est allé sur six ans